welcome back I'm not gonna do a proof of
a trig identity which which i think is
pretty amazing up although i think the
proof isn't that obvious and i'll have
to admit ahead of time this isn't
something that would have a occurred to
me naturally I wouldn't have naturally
drawn this figure just to start off with
but let's just start off with let's just
say we want to figure out some other way
to write the sine sine of alpha plus
beta where alpha and beta are let's say
two separate angles so you know if I had
the sine of you know forty and fifty
degrees right so I'd want to know if I
this would obviously be the sine of 90
which is easy but could I rewrite that
as some you know combination of the sine
of 40 in the sine of 50 or whatever well
I think you'll you'll see where this is
going
so let's go back to this diagram and
let's say that this let me pick a better
color let's say that this is angle alpha
and that this is angle beta all right
then this whole angle right here this
whole angle is angle alpha plus beta
right so we want to figure out the sine
of alpha plus beta well the sine of
alpha plus beta sine of small angle
opposite over hypotenuse opposite this
whole angle is if we if we use this
right angle triangle or this right
triangle triangle BAC opposite is BC so
that equals BC draw a line or it BC over
the hypotenuse a B over a B right BC
over a B is the sine of alpha plus beta
what can we write BC over a B
differently let's see if we can and
probably the person who first figured
out this proof was just playing around
they know they drew this diagram they
start looking can I write BC any
differently well BC this whole length is
the sum of BD and EF and we know that
because this is
on the line right now and you can
figure that out just by looking all the
right angles but this is a horizontal
line so BC is the same thing as BD + ya
so let's write that down BC is the same
thing as BD BD + EF right and then still
all of that over a B all I did is I
wrote rewrote BC as the sum of this
segment and this segment which should
make sense to you hopefully and then we
can of course rewrite that as equal to
BD BD over a B plus EF over a B right so
BD
over a B plus EF over a B and these are
kind of nonsensical ratios right BD over
a B what can I do with that and EF over
a B what can I do with that would it be
more interesting if I could do like BD
over b e that'd be an interesting ratio
right because that would be a segment
over its hypotenuse right so let's let's
see if we can rewrite it somehow like
that well we can just do it we could
just do it mathematically we could say
this is equal to BD over b e B D over B
e
right times b e over a B so this might
seem non-intuitive you but it kind of
makes sense right we we didn't pick B II
completely arbitrarily we said we know
what BD is so let me pick another side
that you know I can do something maybe
maybe with real quick ratios and so I
put I said BD over b e times b e over a
b is equal to BD / AP a lot of confusion
with all these letters but that makes
sense right because these two terms
would just cancel out if we're just
multiplying these fractions and you
would get back
to this top term and let me let me
actually make sure that you understand
that this whoops
the bister m-- and this term are the
same thing and now let's do that second
term we know EF wouldn't it be good if
we could relate EF to something like
it's the hypotenuse of this right
triangle like a e so let's do that so
let's say so let's put the plus sign
there EF EF over a B is the same thing
as EF / AE AE x AE over a B right once
again we're just multiplying fractions
these would cancel out and you would get
this again and let me let me make sure
you understand that this term is the
same thing as this term you can just
multiply out the fractions and that's
what you would get now before we
progress with this whole line of thought
that we're doing let's see if we could
figure out something else interesting
about this about this strange set of
triangles and shapes that I've drawn
it's actually pretty neat if this angle
is alpha well if if we we have line AF
EF is perpendicular to it right and de
is perpendicular to EF right so de this
line and AF are parallel
since AF is parallel to de and then AE
intersects both we know that what is
that the inner angles or I think that's
called inner angles with parallel lines
that this is also equal to alpha right
right you can imagine a parallel long
parallel line here long parallel line
here and then this line intersects both
so if this is a little confusing maybe
you want to review a little bit of that
you know parallel line geometry but I
think this might make sense so this line
this angle is alpha then this angle
right here is is complementary to it so
it's 90 minus L right and if this angle
is 90 minus alpha this angle is
obviously 90 then we know that this
angle Plus this angle Plus this angle
has
one-eighty so we know that this is equal
to alpha if that doesn't make sense to
you think about this alpha plus 90 minus
alpha plus 90 that's a minus minus alpha
plus 90 is what alpha plus 90 minus
alpha so this minus alpha and alpha
cancel out and you just have 90 plus 90
and that equals 180 right so we know
that this angle right here I know it's
getting really small and probably hard
to read but we know that this angle here
is alpha okay so let's get back to what
we were progressing what we were doing
here so what is BD / b BD / b e well
that's the adjacent to this alpha that's
which is the same angle really be D over
B II so it's adjacent over hypotenuse
adjacent over hypotenuse cosine so that
is equal to the cosine of alpha cosine
of alpha and what's B e over a b b:e
over a B well let's if we look at this
larger right triangle that is the
opposite of beta of the angle beta times
its hypotenuse so what's opposite over
hypotenuse so Soh sine so sine of beta
is B e over a B so this is sine of beta
sine of beta and now let me switch to
two magenta what's EF over AE EF / AE if
we look at this right triangle right
here is opposite over hypotenuse for
alpha right so it's sine of alpha
opposite over hypotenuse sine of alpha
and what's a e over a B AE over a B so
now we're looking at this large right
triangle here AE over a B well that's
the adjacent of beta
over the hypotenuse well what's adjacent
over hypotenuse that's the cosine Chi
cosine of beta of this beta right here I
think we're done this is to me fairly
mind-blowing that the sine of alpha plus
beta the sine of alpha plus beta alpha
plus beta is equal to the cosine of
alpha times the sine of beta plus the
sine of alpha times the cosine of beta
what's neat about this is that it kind
of came out in this nice symmetric
formula right it's not it's not this big
hairy thing it's almost you might have
even guessed it I don't know it's I just
find it very neat we went through this
big convoluted proof with this big
convoluted shape but we got this nice
symmetric trig identity out of it so
hopefully you found that amazing as well
and in the next presentation I'll do
proof for cosine of alpha plus beta see
you soon